und wir sprechen jetzt mit jan mewes
erkennt siegfried und roy seit jahren
ist executive producer von einem film
der jetzt über das magier duo mit dem
star produzenten nico hofmann produziert
wird hermes wie sehr trifft sie diese
todesnachricht geschockt weil ich
eigentlich gehofft habe er zwei wäre
eine halbseitige leben um einen schlag
am zahlen und all diesen sachen überlebt
wird 3 martin strobel hat das alles
geschafft
er wird auch diesen virus besiegen aber
ich habe mich leider getäuscht es nicht
geschafft
wann haben sie denn das letzte mal roy
horn gesehen oder gesprochen
ja ich habe ihn auch zuletzt im wir
haben vier stürmer telefoniert aber
wirklich gesehen habe ich ihn auch bei
diesem treffen mit marco wir kurz vor
weihnachten in las vegas war und beim
adventskaffee und es war total nett und
wir hatten unheimlich schöne zeit und
ich hatte mein sohn dabei war damals ein
gutes jahr alt oder dass ich sehr
gefreut im t shirt geschenkt und weiße
tiger und und so nah war wie die marken
auf jedem schon sagte er strengte sich
sehr an aber er war immer positiv und
war echt gut drauf und wir hatten da
habe ich mich von ihm verabschiedet habe
ich habe natürlich nicht gedacht dass
ich ihn nie wiedersehen hatte wir
arbeiten an einem film über das mag ja
de was wird es etwa zu sehen geben wie
weit sind sie in diesen vorbereitungen
für den film ja das macht er
hauptsächlich den nico hofmann mit
seinem team ich war ja letztendlich der
ideengeber für diese für diese
produktion und wir sind jetzt glaube ich
daran dass theorie die die produktion
ist darf ich daran dass in den büchern
in anderen büchern ist und so weiter ich
glaube dass wir ja sicherlich
hoffentlich eines tages ein sehr
würdiges monument und sehr würdiges
denkmal für frei und das glaube ich wird
ihnen dann sehr freut ihn sehr gefreut
hinbekommen werden
jan mewes vielen herzlichen dank für das
gespräch